or mr. go great to see you thank you
very much indeed for coming in and let
me talk about a previous interview you
did with Sky News on this issue of a
deposit return scheme it was back in
July last year you said you wanted to
see one as soon as possible
now can I ask you given that we're in
March the next year when or indeed if
you think a scheme will start in England
yes we're going to go ahead with a
consultation and we want to make sure
that we got the scheme up and running
absolutely as soon as possible we've
been talking to industry in order to
make sure that we listen to all those
who've expressed concerns in the past
and we know now that while there are
some people who we need to work with in
order to make sure that it works that it
will be full steam ahead yeah
but when any indication what are your
thoughts said given the the intervening
period between July and March what are
your thoughts about when one might be
operational well I think the the most
important is to make sure that this
consultation period gets everyone who
has an interest in mobility I think
it'll be a few months time we want to
make sure that we get the widest range
of views reflected the key thing about a
deposit return scheme is that it has the
potential to be a massive alteration in
the way in which we recycle but it's
only one part of a broader set of things
that we wanted to do and we've been
inspired of course by skies ocean rescue
campaign and also by the work of so many
people in civil society who want to
ensure not just that plastic bottles but
also that all of the plastic waste that
we generate is effectively recycled and
a deposit return scheme could be a game
changer but I have to stress important
as it is it's only one part of a broader
network of things that we need to do but
let's just talk about the deposit return
scheme and how one operates where we've
seen in other countries a lot of them
have these these machines these crushing
machines in in corner shop yes is that
the way you are envisaging the one in
Britain going that's one of the ways in
which you could go and that's one of the
reasons why we're having a consultation
in order to make sure that we listen to
small business those those corners shop
stores that that might be responsible
for having some of these machinery and
but also that we want to talk more
broadly to local government as well
because they're responsible at the
moment for so much recycling we want to
make sure that every single part of the
chain can work effectively in order to
ensure the silver
economic considerations on this local
authorities might lose out on the
revenue from recycling and indeed the
corner shops might lose out there's a
big lot of floor space going for these
machines one imagines well it's it is
the case in other countries that people
often want to have these machines
because they draw in traffic actually
and they ensure that there is more
fruitful but it is the case when we look
at local government if it's the case
that we're going to have plastic bottles
going into these machines rather than
going into our bins and going into local
authority recycling we need to ensure
that local authorities get the support
that they need that's why we're also
looking at changing the way in which
producers and all those who use plastic
actually pay into a system which helps
local government and help central
government to recycle more effective
where they pay for the machines as well
well one of the things we need to do is
to be in a position to though whether
it's the soft drink manufacturers or
whether it's others business has to step
up business has to make a contribution
they're the people who are using this
plastic and we need to have a scheme
that doesn't just raise the revenue for
recycling but also creates an incentive
for those manufacturers to move away
sometimes from using what's called
virgin material ie plastic that hasn't
itself been recycled towards more
recycled material it's trying to make
sure that you get a virtuous circle are
you using data from the plastic bag
scheme which has been a tremendous
success in in cutting though in cutting
down that usage and therefore thinking
about the the pricing here what yes AWS
it might be put on the bottles
absolutely there's a there's the you're
absolutely right that the plastic bag
scheme has been a huge success and as a
result we've seen a more than eighty
percent reduction in plastic bag use as
a result of a simple challenge being
placed on all bags if we look at other
countries whether that's Germany or
Sweden that have used deposit return
schemes they have a variable rate again
one of the things we want to consult on
is what's the right rate in order to
encourage the right level of recycling
and at the same time to make it
effective and efficient for industry
whether those are the soft drink
companies or the the corner shops that
might be installing some of those
deposit machines and just lastly can I
push you for a date when you think it
might come into operation subject to
consultation we've got all that what
about a year's time to coincide with
brexit I think it would be a great
brexit bonus but I didn't want it to be
specifically told I'm sorry to be
open-minded on this issue I need to make
sure that the consultation listens to
everyone because we've got to get it
right it's better to get it right and to
ensure that by the time certainly well
before the next election that people see
this scheme up and running they're
confident that we've done the right
thing